yeah what's your story my friend yeah
your friend
no I know a guy right there right was
like you know what's it like you know am
I gay so he went to a forest a magical
for us a magical forest magical for us
we're the guy playing a flute with dicks
out
yeah
yeah it's in the Mist Puff the Magic
Dragon and he went to the edge of the
Forest right in a magical gay man walked
out yeah right a magical gay man right
isn't that redundant it is sorry yeah
yeah and then I think my body magical
period then my body saw that he had his
pants down and my buddy pushed him went
back into his car and said yeah I'm not
gay but he went to that length what I
want to know is he pushed him with this
guy on him or something no he a magical
moment comes out no and you go no pushed
him away I don't want to suck your [__]
and what I did was I went I'll take up
and you did it you stepped I didn't go I
got four I stepped to the mic the mic
yeah okay so what's this then oh my God
because it's I don't want to talk about
this anymore wanting to suck dick can't
be the only prerequisite for whether or
not you feel you know a little gay or
about well that's you're gonna have to
meet that that well like for me say for
instance like what else I like making
out with girls I like the company of
girls I feel sexual yours is a little
different than men I would love to be
eaten out by a girl but I don't
particularly love [__] I don't I've
tried it multiple times and I'm like oh
this is not the sport for me I don't
what how many times you reach gayness
like how many how many like how many
[__] do you eat where you go you're
officially gay you you hit the line I
don't know is there a limit where you go
if I hit 15 I'm gay or did you stop at
12 I don't know it was like the last
time I I say it's 30 dicks and then
you're gay 30. what are you at what are
you at at two okay yes I got 28 more to
go you look like you're going to
accomplish
the climbing snatches
I don't know because it's like all [__]
is it just differs I think so maybe my
my second experience was really trauma I
saw you on a date with that beautiful
girl yeah she's so beautiful right she's
like oh my God she's Next Level yeah but
it didn't feel right for me yeah it
didn't feel right I gave no energy you
gave no good energy what was my energy
like we're friends like we we go in the
water together
dude she was looking at her like
so you were trying were you trying to do
this is she trying to be aware you're
like dudes because I have sexual
feelings I've had threesomes with like
women and men and I enjoy like the whole
thing I was like oh maybe that's that's
sad but yeah maybe you're right like I'd
maybe like outside of a threesome at the
context of a threesome maybe I'm not
attracted you're more like the dudes you
like dudes but I like yeah but I like
the company of girls let me ask you let
me give you a scenario let's say you and
I on the road Godfrey and Bobby Lee show
we're in Cincinnati all right right we
see the most beautiful girl in the world
yeah she's like I want to make love to
both of you oh right but can we black
and yellow black and yellow black can we
do it at the same time would you nah why
let you go first not with you hell no
why you'll be like let me get him back
at you
that's exactly
come on
[__] yeah
come on it'd be fun though it would be
no it would not yeah
that would be fine I'm a regular guy
yeah one-on-one chick or if there's too
cool yeah my first one was with two
Japanese girls that was cool man I I
didn't expect it uh threes I didn't do a
lot of that my friends did but I always
was I was always with women that didn't
want to do that [__] I always got those
it was like [__] but I I was I my first
one was two Japanese girls
and uh they have access they have
accents yeah they were real Japanese
like real did they do this it was like
okay
yeah I had two and then I did another
one with um these two girls that I was
messing with like separately and then
they came to my house it was like four
in the morning I'm watching ESPN and I
was like oh [__] no I thought they were
like you [__] we're both gonna
[__] you now I was like okay what yeah
it was amazing I didn't know you know
some girls combined except yeah he
cheated on me too yeah and they combined
it and throw wine in your face and go
yeah high five in Thelma and Louise it
out these girls came in and said okay
since you [__] us both might as well
do it yeah it was great that was just
too but I don't get threesomes all the
time like one of those magical black men
like in every mile yeah right
Jack Nance what's this oh that's bagger
van Oh you mean all the service